[Music]
meagan Merkel and Prince Harry's lives
have dramatically changed in the two
years since they said I do when you
reflect on what's happened it could
almost be a decade that has cost now
it's he is taking a look at their
biggest developments between year one
and year two you couldn't get a greater
contrast between the anniversary this
year and our anniversary last year
starting with welcoming their first
child son Archie Harrison
mountbatten-windsor Megan gave birth to
baby Sussex on May 6 mere weeks before
the couple's first wedding anniversary
on May 19th and I have the two best guys
in the world
which is a thrill to have at the time
she and Harry were still getting settled
into their newly renovated home in
Windsor England and according to royal
expert Katie Nichol there was no reason
to suspect any of the events that
unfolded next there wasn't at that stage
any indication that we'll be here today
determined to make this work Megan had
committed to making but by last summer
the couple seemed to be fed up with
being under constant media scrutiny the
man has been a result of circumstances
that grease the really sausage comes to
the surface last summer there's still a
lot of open wounds here and everything
boiled over while thus Essex's were on
their 10-day royal tour of Africa and
early fall it's just been a really
special trip despite bringing a then
four month old Archie along everything's
based on Archie's few times and all the
glowing press they were suddenly
receiving love this place I got meeting
the people the energy the couple dropped
this bombshell on the second-to-last day
of their trip this announcement that a
couple of taking action against the Mail
on Sunday has come as a complete
surprise in fact and it's not just the
press pack who've been taken by surprise
Palisades also apparently didn't know
that this was coming I always protect my
family and now I have a fountain to
protect we learned the extent of Megan
and Harry's frustrations with the media
when they got candid like never before
in the documentary Harry and Megan an
African journey every single time I see
a camera every single time I hear a
click every single time I see a flash it
takes me straight back I guess and also
thank you for asking because not many
people have asked if I'm okay but it's
it's a very real thing to be going
through behind the scenes and the answer
is would it be fair to say no really
okay it's really been a struggle yes
when it came time to celebrate the
holidays with the royal family Megan and
Harry opted out instead jetting off to
Canada's Vancouver Island for some
much-needed family time everything
seemed to be business as usual when the
couple carried out their first official
royal engagement of 2020 but the
following day on January 8 Megan and
Harry announced bombshell number two
Harry and Megan making that major
surprise announcement saying they are
stepping back from royal duties to end
plan to spend a lot more time here in
North America the news apparently
catching the Queen off-guard and if you
thought things between Harry and Big
Brother William were bad before
well this made the rift even worse it
turns out it's not so much what they did
it's how they did it after lots of
thought in a big family meeting the
Queen rejected Harry and Megan's idea to
step down as senior Royals while working
towards financial independence and
continuing to support her majesty and
gave them an ultimatum
instead I hope that helps you understand
what did it come to but I would step my
family back from all I've ever known
just to take a step forward into what I
hope can be a more peaceful life Megan
and Harry made their official royal exit
on March 31st and then shocked us again
by making a surprise move to LA where
they've been quarantined
amid the corona virus pandemic they are
looking in several parts of California
for for a family base so this is just a
stopgap this is a place they feel owned
by Tyler Perry meanwhile they've been
busy at work on their new foundation
arch well you're never really satisfied
I'm not proud until in my mind that
we've actually really made a difference
that for me is the definition of success
and despite Megan and Harry's whirlwind
year Katy Nichol tells ET that they're
closer than ever
years in they're still very much in love
they're a partnership and that if
anything and the challenges and the
obstacles of this past year has only
brought them closer I mean they were
close to begin with and getting through
all of this and this absolutely faith in
creating a new life themselves has has
brought them closer we can't wait to see
what this next year brings these two I
would hope that people the world will
get to a point where you see us as a
couple who's in love right I'm Megan and
I married this incredible man and this
to me is just part of our love story
[Music]